vengo a compartirles el día de hoy una
serie de reflexiones de perspectivas
sobre innovación y sobre emprendimiento
tecnológico hace ya casi cinco años salí
del ecuador para estudiar un doctorado
de este tema porque me parece
interesante me parecía algo que vemos en
otros países vemos lugares como eeuu que
tienen estos estas startups que crecen
en cuestión de años y que transforman
totalmente la forma como vivimos
entonces mientras estaba allá tuve la
oportunidad de poder desarrollar y
desarrollar mi propio emprendimiento
tecnológico con la ayuda de un equipo y
tenemos un sueño tenemos el sueño de
poder generar tecnología para enfrentar
la polución plástica queremos generar
datos que pueden servir para la política
pública y estos datos puedan ser usados
para actuar de mejor manera frente a
este grave problema
pero mientras estaba en esto mientras
estaba
en el tema de levantar fondos logramos
levantar casi un millón de libras
esterlinas para este proyecto hemos
tenido apoyo internacional y lo queremos
traer acá al ecuador me ponía a pensar
qué podemos hacer para generar
emprendimientos tecnológicos aquí en el
país
y ese es el motivo de la charla del día
de hoy
que nos hace falta como sociedad para
poder crear más startups de este tipo
que quizás sueñen con cambiar no sólo la
realidad de nuestro país sino también la
realidad de otros sectores de la
sociedad y del mundo
entonces mientras estaba allá cuando no
está fuera del país los que han vivido
afuera podrán entender lo que yo les voy
a comentar es duro uno extraña el país
todos los días incluso la comida los
amigos una sonrisa incluso con el señor
de taxi estas cosas no pasan en otros
lugares
entonces me di cuenta de que algo muy
importante son incluso los conceptos la
parte semántica que muchas veces
hablamos de estos conceptos aquí
hablamos de innovación pero me di cuenta
que hay diferencias e incluso en la
parte semántica de lo que nosotros
creemos versus los conceptos que se
tienen allá
en el término de innovación esos tienen
una conexión me refiero a esos todos los
países desarrollados a invenciones
comercializables qué quiere decir eso
que están generando inventos con una
necesidad de mercado
luego reflexionando hacia atrás viendo
colegas acá en el país o gente que
quiere emprender me di cuenta que no
había esa conexión muchas veces muchas
veces generamos inventos o generamos
elementos que no necesariamente van a
tener un valor comercial
y luego otro concepto del concepto de
emprendimiento y emprender no
necesariamente necesitamos innovar para
emprender emprender es la creación de un
nuevo negocio aveces replicamos ideas de
otros lugares oa veces simplemente
incluso copiamos las ideas existentes
que vemos que están resultando exitosos
aquí en aquí en el país
pero ahora estos dos conceptos
emprendimiento e innovación como los
podemos medir resulta que si si vemos la
tasa de emprendimiento del ecuador según
el global entrepreneurship monitor
estamos en primer lugar en la región
cinco años seguidos somos el país más
emprendedor de la región
pero cuando vemos el tema de innovación
el tema de invenciones comercializables
estamos en el puesto 96 de 137 países
qué está pasando un país lleno de
emprendimiento pero no tenemos
innovación
ahora es puede no tener emprendimiento
hay otros países que a pesar de las
crisis las personas que emprenden
simplemente botan los brazos si hay algo
bueno en el ecuatoriano ahí es ahí esa
capacidad de emprender crear cosas pues
nos falta un poco entender cómo innovar
hacia dónde podemos ir en este sentido
qué podemos hacer como país hay
conceptos sobre el tema de innovación
podemos ver que el ecuador está en una
curva de crecimiento en la cual
inicialmente la gente está emprendiendo
por necesidad la gente emprende porque
no tiene un empleo o porque por ejemplo
perdió su trabajo entonces hay que dar
este salto en nuestra sociedad para que
la gente no solo emprenda por una
necesidad sino porque es oportuno porque
es atractivo entender
cómo hacemos esto como lo logramos como
sociedad como damos este salto hacia la
oportunidad y luego hacia la innovación
hemos escuchado mucho sobre este tema
hemos escuchado que hay varias cosas que
le hacen falta al ecosistema del ecuador
pero que tal nuestra cultura cómo está
el tema de la cultura ecuatoriana versus
la innovación
existen barreras las personas que han
logrado emprender o que han intentado
emprender
incluso innovar como nos ha pasado que
hemos sentido en este tema entonces se
nota que hay hay un tema hay un problema
que nosotros podemos tener
culturalmente hablando
si pensamos en la percepción del
producto local les cuento una anécdota
yo trabajaba para una ensambladora aquí
en el país esta ensambladora
yo tenía siempre el uniforme de la
ensambladora entonces me subí a los
taxis los señores del taxi siempre me
veían y me ponen mala cara desde el
inicio sólo por el uniforme entonces la
conversación empezaba me sigan porque
hacen carros tan malos
era como
pero por qué me dice eso entonces
después de un tiempo de la conversación
saben cuál era la respuesta era porque
era ecuatoriana
yo siempre le decía pero usted también
ecuatoriano
tenemos esa
entonces tenemos de este problema de
alguna forma pensamos que lo ecuatoriano
es malo
eso es grave porque al mismo tiempo nos
quejamos del problema de desempleo aquí
hay una oportunidad de mejorar para
nosotros como país apoyemos a las
empresas locales apoyamos a los
emprendedores cada emprendedor es
alguien que trata de dar trabajo no sólo
para su familia o en comida sino para
otras personas así sucedió en otros
países así sucedió en alemania después
de la segunda guerra mundial de 2 japón
después de bombas nucleares entonces
ayudémonos ayudemos nos compremos cosas
locales esto va a generar más empleo
vamos a otra percepción cultural
ya son 10 años que hemos escuchado una
retórica en contra del empresario o en
contra del emprendedor
que nos va a pasar como sociedad si la
principal fuente de empleo para más del
80 por ciento de ecuatorianos es algo
que es percibido como algo malo
es igual está mal como como le podemos
decir a las nuevas generaciones que
vienen emprendan generen nuevos empleos
si escuchamos una retórica que nos está
diciendo el empresario es malo el
empresario de opresor no es así quizás
necesitamos también como empresarios
como emprendedores tener una conciencia
social pagar justo pero necesitamos que
creer que es algo bueno crear más
empleos y generar más emprendimientos en
el país
otro tema otra oportunidad de mejora que
tenemos es conocernos más
he escuchado muchas veces que me dicen
oye pero qué hago
qué hago como emprendimiento bueno qué
hacer ya está todo hecho entonces esto
es preocupante el ecuador es un país en
desarrollo hay muchísimo por hacer
tenemos un montón de oportunidades y
saben cómo podemos identificar esas
oportunidades cuando escuchamos las
quejas nosotros nos quejamos mucho de
esas quejas se pueden transformar en
oportunidades que nosotros podemos
resolver ese es el primer paso para
empezar a pensar más de nosotros
aprendamos de los casos de éxito hay
empresarios emprendedores del país que
han hecho cosas espectaculares pero no
las conocemos y conocemos historias de
gente de fuera del país conozcamos los
más conozcamos los casos de éxito que
existen en el ecuador preocupemos los
más de nuestra cultura
mientras estamos en este proceso hacia
dónde vamos ya empezamos a escuchar
conceptos de la cuarta revolución
industrial los sistemas ivr físicos que
suena cosas como medias raras puro
robots y dónde está el ecuador cómo nos
adaptamos a esto donde creen que está el
ecuador en estas revoluciones
industriales la primera en la segunda en
la tercera o en la cuarta la respuesta
es que estos cuadros son hechos por
países desarrollados que han tenido un
crecimiento homogéneo ellos pasaron de
la primera a la segunda la tercera y la
cuarta nosotros no tenemos ese
desarrollo es un desarrollo más
heterogéneo eso quiere decir que hay
pocas industrias que son las únicas que
quizás puedan ir a la cuarta revolución
industrial pero hay muchísimas que
incluso no han llegado a la primera
qué pasa con la agricultura en muchos
sectores del norte de nuestro país que
todavía ni siquiera la parte mecánica
del gas entonces hay una necesidad
enorme de conocerlos más y de ver que
existen muchísimas oportunidades el
campo la industria y la agroindustria
tiene un poder enorme en nuestro país y
estamos empezando a ver casos de éxito
cuando empezamos a creer en los
productos que podemos crear y también en
las potencialidades que tenemos como
sociedad
como estamos en el tema de colaboración
colaboramos a veces nos guardamos las
ideas es como que decimos esto si digo
me copian ya no emprenden
desafortunadamente necesitamos colaborar
ya no existen los emprendimientos como
era en el pasado steve jobs y wozniak
por ejemplo hace más de 20 años en un
garaje creando computadoras ya no es así
la innovación ahora es colaborativa ya
no estamos ya no podemos evolucionar o
innovar como individuos se dan clusters
de innovación tenemos que aprender a
colaborar como país hacer grupos de
trabajo interdisciplinarios si sabemos
la parte técnica
hagamos alianzas con gente que sepa la
parte comercial
pensemos en trabajar en conjunto para
poder de esa forma generar estos
emprendimientos que tanto necesitamos en
el país
resumiendo un poco el tema de la charla
yo creo que innovar es un derecho creo
que tenemos que empezar a creer en eso
creo que las nuevas generaciones tenemos
una responsabilidad ya no solo con
nosotros mismos sino con nuestro
ambiente
sabemos que tenemos más o menos entre 10
a 15 años para que el problema de la
polución y cambio climático genera
efectos irreversibles entonces tenemos
que empezar a tratar de evolucionar como
sociedad los emprendimientos
tecnológicos son una oportunidad que no
hemos tenido antes emprendimientos
tecnológicos como les decía tienen una
relación con la innovación innovación es
invenciones comercializables inventemos
tengamos esa capacidad de crear nuevas
cosas
cuáles son los temas culturales que
podemos resolver nos hablamos el día de
hoy el tema de compremos productos
locales cada vez que compramos un
producto local por más que no sea tan
bueno comparado con algo que está afuera
damos empleo a muchas personas
fomentemos del emprendimiento fomentemos
de esa cultura de emprender ayudemos a
la gente que emprende porque es gente
que va a tratar de dar empleo a otras
personas
y finalmente conozcamos los más
conozcamos casos de éxito conozcamos
nuestros propios problemas
entendamos como una sociedad que está en
desarrollo y tiene muchas oportunidades
si lo logramos quizás podemos resolver
el problema que a todos nos aquejan que
es la falta de empleos adecuados yo creo
que vamos a poder hacer que el ecuador
en el ecuador
innovar sea un derecho muchas gracias